so the time has come sooner than
expected
but in the last video i posted in that
video i promised that if it got 3000
likes
i would share a really cool game between
carlson and carwana and just two hours
after i i posted the video it surpassed
3 000 likes so here we are
and i'm really looking forward to
sharing this game because it's a really
cool one and it features the exact same
opening that we saw in yesterday's video
the london opening
and more specifically we're gonna see a
line in the london with uh an early
night h5
from black this is a move that grand
master marie sabog played against me
and this is what caruana played against
carlson in 2020. now the game that they
played was actually played only chess it
was part of the st louis chess club's
clutch chess event that was played uh in
june 2020 so is a round kind of the the
boom of the online events
during the pandemic
and uh i wish i had studied this game
before gibraltar because carlson played
uh just a really nice model game from
this variation
so he played the same move that i played
uh is dc5 and after takes takes queen a5
um here he played bishop to d3
now if you didn't watch my previous
video i played the move c4 in this
position
and it went into a lot of kind of
tactical sharp variations
but magnus being magnus goes for a more
kind of steady and positional approach
allows black to take back on c5 and
castles
and the next several moves are
pretty straightforward for both players
black just completing development
white uh improves at night with tempo
against the queen
aviano retreats and queen d2 bishop g7
c3 castling rookie one and bishop g4 so
so far nothing really too special from
either side
even the top players in the world they
still follow opening principles from
time to time
and with bishop g4 black is of course
threatening to take and give white
triple pawns
so white doesn't have too many options
here i do like the move that magnus
played queen to e3
very simply centralizing the queen
reinforcing the knights also
pressuring e-file a bit
and here carwana decides to take
immediately on f3
which at first i thought was a little
bit surprising given that black
had the bishop hair and uh very quickly
just gives it up
but then i realized that lightsword
bishop for black doesn't really have a
great place especially if h3 is coming
black probably wants to trade before
white can land and move like 95.
so after takes takes
e6
and uh here i think it's safe to say
that we've officially left opening and
the players are entering the middle game
and this is where white can start trying
to formulate some plans
i think a lot of players here would very
simply just improve the rook rook 81
but magnus decides to start with the
move h4 which of course is going for h5
and very much in the style of stockfish
or lila just pushing the h pawn trying
to grab space and potentially attack on
the king side
so fabiano wants none of this he plays
h5 himself and then magnus plays a very
solid move g3
and uh from white's perspective it makes
sense to keep the pawns on the dark
squares because white has lights for
bishop and usually in cases like this
the way to maximize square control is to
have the pawns control the dark squares
have the bishop control light squares
even though it's still a very solid
position for both sides
i do already kind of like the the piece
harmony that white has going on so the
game continues rook fe-8 rook 81 proving
the final piece in the position
and now black plays a6 probably going
for some queen side expansion would be
very logical to go for b5 and eventually
b4 especially combined with the fiancato
dark square bishop
and here we reach a point where
white pretty much has everything fully
optimized it seems like
and it's a question
what to do next
and i think a position like this can
really separate
a an amateur player from a strong grand
master especially someone like magnus
carlsen
and
i really like the move that magnus
played here because he identified
essentially his worst place piece in the
position
and very quickly turned his worst piece
into his best piece
so i'll go ahead and show the move is
knight to d2
uh which looks a little bit passive it
is retreating but it's not about where
the knight
is gone it's about where the knight is
going
and uh if we just play one more move
pawn b5 we're gonna see white's really
nice idea and this idea it's positional
but it's also tactical it's knight to e4
and the knight can't be taken thanks to
the x-ray vision along the d-file
if black were to take the knight then
white would be winning material
uh because the queen is hit the knights
hit and if the queen moves then white
can take and hit both rooks
so knight e4 was uh was very clever from
magnus and i'm sure he saw this uh back
when his knight was on b3 it's to play a
knight e4 force a queen to move and then
find a very nice square on g5 here we
see that white is putting a lot of
pressure
on the king side from relatively early
on in the middle game so here the game
continues rook 88 bishop t2
uh nice move unleashing the rook and uh
just getting the bishop to a slightly
preferable square
and here fabiano makes the first clear
mistake of the game what he probably
should have done is just waited and been
patient and played a move like bishop f6
and just see what white is gonna do next
it's very possible this could have
prompted white to repeat after 94 bishop
g7 knight g5 perhaps magnus would uh
would try and play on for more of an
advantage
but the move that carwana played here
was pawn to b4
and this is a double-edged move on one
hand it does uh try and weaken white's
queen side but on the other hand it
allows the bishop to find a very nice
square
on a4 and this is what magnus played to
shish kebab all of these pieces
on the light squares
and as we're gonna see b4 just did more
damage to black's position
than it did to white's position
so here black took on c3 white took back
and then queen c8 so getting off the
diagonal
unfortunately for black the play was a
little bit slow and passive
and this gave magnus the perfect
opportunity to strike
and in this position he came up with a
really beautiful move that i think a lot
of players just wouldn't consider here
is a move pawn to f5
and usually when there's a square that's
controlled by two of the opponent pawns
and only supported by your queen then
such a move is off limits but here white
takes advantage of the fact that
uh whichever pawn takes there's going to
be things hanging
if the g pawn takes then each pawn will
be undefended and if the e pawn takes
then d5 will be undefended
and already black is under serious
serious pressure
in the game
fabiano took on f5 with the g-pawn
and i was really impressed with magnus's
next move because it looks like
queen jigs h5 is a no-brainer
but uh then black would play rook e7 and
it's not entirely clear how light can
follow through with attack queen h7 is
met with king f8
and perhaps there's still some survival
chances left for black
so instead of going into this line
magnus started with a move pawn c4
and the difference here is that the
queen stays on f3 which essentially pins
upon to the knight on c6 as white you
can very safely take the pawn whenever
you feel like it so there's really no
rush to take on h5
and essentially what magnus is doing is
creating multiple weaknesses for black
to deal with and usually when there's
multiple targets to attack then it's
easier to uh to win material and come
out on top
so fabiano here played knight d4
which is an attempt to muddy the waters
and try and make things a bit
complicated because now the queen is
attacked by the knights but at the same
time the rook is attacked on e8s
and i think uh this move may have been a
bit of desperation because as we're
going to see
white is in full control after the move
rook takes d4
a very temporary exchange sacrifice but
really this is just trading bishop takes
d4 bishop takes e8 rook takes e8 and
finally magnus takes on h5
and it's nice to do so in this position
because without the bishop on g7 there
is a very simple maiden two threat with
either queen h7 queen f7 or queen f7
queen h7
so black has to respond plays a move
queen c7 defending the pawn
but unfortunately for black the king is
a little bit too naked and white is just
the one having all the fun uh c takes d5
was played rookie 7
d takes e6
and uh yeah the the pawn 96 is now
supported by the knight and the rook
and things just go downhill very quickly
for black pawn f6 queen g6 king f8
knight 3 bishop c3
and i do really like the way that magnus
finished off the game because even
though it looks like there should be
some sort of mating that against the
black king
magnus chose a different route starting
with the move rook c1 pinning the bishop
to the queen and after rook takes e6 he
plays a really nice centralizing move
knight to d4 hitting the rook hitting
the pawn taking advantage of the pin
black is in shambles fabiano plays rook
b6
and after queen h6 king g8 white doesn't
go for mate here but rather goes for the
free snack on
c3 and there's no way to defend the
bishop
and fabiano resigns in this position
losing in 37 moves against the london
opening this was a really nice smooth
game for magnus it started relatively
positionally but
some really nice play in the middle game
with uh first optimizing the position
finding this very clever night maneuver
to g5
and then i think the star move of the
game was this
pawn f5 thrust which just busted open
box position
so i hope viewers can learn a thing or
two from this game i certainly did it's
always a treat to see magnus carlsen
play the london opening and win in
spectacular fashion
so again i do appreciate all the love
from the previous video feel free to
like this video as well
and stay tuned for more content